how did I find my passion I'm going to
answer that question in today's episode
of ask Evan
so Risa got a question for one of my
loyal YouTube viewers kachelle who wrote
in the say how did you find your passion
and what were the difficulties that you
faced your journey here and how did you
deal with it
that's a great question you want to have
an answer for a while so I'm happy to
retell the story
my passion for entrepreneurs started
almost by fluke I had sold my first
business and I didn't know what to do
next with my life and so I followed my
own advice and just started to explore
and I said yes the whole bunch of
opportunities and one of them was the
YMCA my local YMCA asked me to come and
speak at one of their places to their
group of entrepreneurs they had this
entrepreneur program young entrepreneurs
who are trying to build businesses and
they wanted me to come and speak to
their students and I thought sure why
not I'll say yes I'll try and see if I
like it and so I spent two weeks
preparing for this presentation and
working on it and wanted to put all of
my heart effort and love into providing
an amazing value and I remember the day
came close and I was promoting it before
telling people hey come out to this
event and I was so nervous I hadn't done
a lot of speaking I met Burke kind of
walking up to the YMCA my heart's
beating faster my palms are getting
sweaty and I walk into the door and get
to the elevator and push the button and
we booked this huge room way to go and
speak at I get to the door and take one
last deep breath like this is it we're
gonna start I was so nervous and I
walked into the room and there were
three people in the room and my heart
stopped and I felt like a total failure
I felt like man I can't get anybody to
show up to a free event and the YMCA was
pointed to their students and I thought
you know what the show has to go on they
came out and it was it was awesome those
three people they came out as changed
entrepreneurs they had new ideas and new
motivations to help them grow their
business and it felt so good I think
that was the most important thing for me
I came alive I felt so amazing during
and after it I was kind of walking on a
cloud going home and despite being so
super nervous and afraid going into it
I did it anyway and and had a lot of fun
with it and knew that I had to find a
way and I think with with all matters of
the heart you know when it's the right
thing to do you know when it feels like
it's the right thing to do when it's
something that makes you come alive and
you're just feeling it and you can't
wait to get up and go do that again that
was the high I got from that speaking
engagement and I couldn't wait to go and
do it again I was looking for my next
opportunity I had so much fun the
challenge was you know I didn't get paid
to do that it was a free thing only
three people came out and looking at
from a logical you know brain point of
view how would I ever make money doing
this right there was no logical way if I
can't get people to come to a free event
how would I ever be able to pay for this
how would ever be able make a career and
living from this and it didn't matter
right because I loved it so much
even if I had to go do something else I
would do that I keep doing this because
I loved it so much I think that's how
you know and and over you know that was
maybe 12 years ago over that course I've
changed my model around a lot and I've
tried a lot of different things and now
I get paid to go and do speaking gigs
and it's evolved - it came from a
website and became a YouTube channel and
it's always evolved around helping
entrepreneurs and it all came out of
that one
YMCA event that was a total failure
failure in most people's eyes but for me
was amazing and I knew I had to keep
going so if you don't know what your
passion is you still trying to discover
it won't and try stuff right say yes
people invite you to things people give
you opportunities I mean it may feel
scary for you and may feel like you're
stepping outside your comfort zone
that's where you learn that's where you
have fun that's where you develop right
you're not going to develop anything
staying inside your box staying inside
your circle of comfort and so by saying
yes to those opportunities and I said
yes so a whole bunch of other stuff that
I wasn't that excited about I didn't get
that same energy and passion from but
I'll say yes almost anything once and
then see where it goes from there and so
if you're trying to discover that
passion encourage you to say yes explore
I see what you fall in love with see
what just makes sense to you and even if
you're not good at it
even if you you know on paper looks like
you'll never be successful at it
there's tons of reasons why you
shouldn't do it the only reason it
really counts is that you feel it here I
hit my microphone with that matters
here you feel it here right strongly
like you can't wait to go and do it
again the next day when you found that
then you have to find a way to keep
going and going and going because that's
the only way you're gonna be happy it's
you I'm gonna make a lot of money that's
the only we're gonna have a huge impact
on the world it's the only way you're
really gonna feel fulfilled
follow your passion thank you for the
question I hope that helped you guys I'd
love to know how you found your passion
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious about your story and I'm
gonna join in the discussion with you
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon